[Music]
one of the philosophy
public talk series that i'm particularly
proud of
and people have taken a lot of interest
in and i've derived a lot of enjoyment
from
is called the worlds of speculative
fiction now it started
in 2016 as an in-person
monthly session series hosted by the
brookfield public library if you don't
know where brookfield is
it's a suburb of milwaukee located to
the west
and so we we started doing this once we
moved back here to
to our hometown of milwaukee and the
library was very kind to host us
we went on year after year until
2000 when covid19 forced us to take a
little bit of a hiatus
and then we figured out that we could we
could do it online and that's what we've
been doing
over a series of months and probably
will continue to do so
until it's safe to hold in-person
sessions again and in each
of the sessions except for the very
first one which was sort of an
introduction to
the whole idea of the talk series which
at that time was scheduled just for one
year
we we talk about worlds and we talk
about world building so we're talking
about
narrative universes that can be found
in works of authors spanning
multiple stories sometimes spanning a
whole set of
novels with spin-offs and
and things like that and so we would do
we'd spend a lot of time talking about
that
you know a little bit less time talking
about character and plot more about the
narrative universe and then we would
talk about the biography of the author
what they went through how they ended up
writing the things that they did
and we would go into several
philosophical themes as well it was very
participatory
generally i would tell people hey if you
got a question you got a comment you
want to make it go ahead
i'll get us back on track and so we had
a lot of really great discussions
over the years a sort of cadre
of regular attendees formed and
and would show up you know month after
month after month many of them gave some
great suggestions
for who we ought to do next and you know
after the 2016 series i was invited to
come back for 2017
18 and it just kept continuing from
there and i think that we probably have
enough material that i could keep doing
this
the rest of my life because there are so
many great
speculative fiction authors out there
and so many cool narrative universes
for us to explore
like i said the the you know the
previous iteration of the talk series
was in the brookfield public library we
pitched it to them
originally and they were pretty
enthusiastic about it
and the reason why i wanted to talk
about this a little bit the reason why
i pitched this series is you know i'd
already done some talk series
at other libraries in kingston
new york and fayetteville north carolina
and i wanted to continue doing that here
in the milwaukee
area so i thought to myself well you
know i've been getting back
into reading fantasy
and science fiction authors who i liked
as a teenager
in my 20s wouldn't it be cool if i could
do a talk series
about that and then i could indulge
myself in what we call guilty pleasure
reading you know go back and read some
tolkien
or c.s lewis or even void some of the
first people that i did for the series
and think about what's going on
philosophically
in these these stories as well as talk
about you know the world
and and all the cool things and get to
chat with other people about it
so that's what i did and the series like
i said you know 2016 got filled up very
quickly
and then they asked would you do another
one and i was like well
yeah there's lots of authors for us to
get to so the 2017 we hit on some other
authors
who i wanted to have in the first series
but didn't and i got some
recommendations
from other people and and the series has
kind of taken on
a life of its own not only do i get
recommendations from
from people who were attending the
face-to-face sessions
and a lot of those were great things
that i would not originally
have come up with on my own you know
like ian banks culture
series for example but
we also had a lot of people giving ideas
uh over the internet you know commenting
on videos hey why don't you do
uh a series or a talk on this author or
this one and so i started to a couple
years back put it
into towards the end of the year a vote
you know give me your suggestions the
night and then i took authors
who had multiple suggestions and i
made a sort of vote that people could
participate in
and that's how i derived some of the
other authors
who i've i've you know been working on
in the series and so as i mentioned we
had to shift entirely online after
covid19
for a while we thought that we might
come out of it fairly quickly and then
go back to face-to-face things
as it became clear that covid19
was here for a much longer duration than
we originally
thought i decided to try out a new
format
which i think i began in in august where
i would create a video and that that
video would premiere
about an hour and a half on a particular
author particular text particular
narrative universe and we would do live
chat on the side
and then after that we would have a
zoom session with video conferencing for
those who wanted to have a more
in-depth discussion and you know we
it's not exactly face to face but we
could at least see each other's
faces and so that's what we've been
doing so when you look at the series
the later ones are all just the videos
that premiered we don't record
the zoom sessions that way people can
you know feel free to participate in in
whatever way they want to
we should talk a little bit about what
is this this term speculative fiction
because some people might say well
i've heard of science fiction or i've
heard of this kind of fiction what's
speculative fiction
so it's like a big umbrella term that
covers a lot
of different genres which includes
science fiction
includes fantasy includes horror
but it spans a lot more as well it
includes what we would call
supernatural and weird tales which are
kind of like horror but maybe also like
fantasy in certain respects that may
involve some aspects of science fiction
it also involves alternate history
or utopian and dystopian literature
apocalyptic and post-apocalyptic
literature
what we might call mythopoetic things
which often
intersect with with some of these even
comedic genres you might think about
douglas
adams and his hitchhiker's guide
series or piers anthony xanthe which is
full of humor
all of those fall under the rubric of
speculative fiction
so if any of them could be fair game
for what it is that we're doing the main
the main thing that we need is there has
to be some sort of narrative universe
that we can explore and some
philosophical depth
and themes that we can you know identify
and then talk about in in the work so
i should talk a little bit as well about
how philosophy connects with us
so a lot of these authors have actually
read philosophy
and sometimes are influenced clearly by
different philosophers
or have their characters talk about or
think about things
in philosophical ways ways that are
clearly indebted to philosophy
we can also use philosophy sometimes to
illuminate
what's going on within the narrative
universe
the you know uh sort of second reality
that that's created
within the novels or short stories or
whatever they they happen to be which
sometimes bleed over into
our ordinary we call it real life as
well
and certainly proliferate through the
internet
uh in certain cases you know with
websites
and uh some of these authors engaging in
blogging
explaining their works so all of that
falls within the ambit
of what we talk about in in this the
last thing that i want to talk about
before i let you go on to enjoy the
playlist
of videos and particular talks
that you want to focus on is that there
is a free online class that i created
in the study with sadler academy which
i'm going to be in the process of
updating
this coming year i i created the class
originally to support the talk series
but i think it's also a great locus for
people to come
in and check out the resources that are
available
in some sort of structured way you can
sort of pick and choose which authors
you want to look at so you might want to
check out the free
online class it's a
you know a nice resource for people as i
mentioned i'll be updating it pretty
soon
so i invite you to take a look at any of
the videos
in this series the authors who you're
interested in perhaps authors that you
haven't heard of and find out about the
the depth and the richness and the
incredible intensity and complexity of
the narrative worlds that these
brilliant authors
have created
you